ميلا الزهراني تتالق بعملين ضخمين في
السباق الرمضاني هو النجم ماجد المصري في
دور ضرب نار وهند نزار تخرج من عباءه
البنت الريفيه في المتمرد واخيرا يتصدر
المشاهدات لكن بطلته مستاءه اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
دفعه لندن مسلسل ضمن السباق الرمضاني هذا
العام للكاتبه هبه مشاري حماده اللي كانت
عملت من قبل دفعه القاهره ودفعه بيروت
ولقوا نجاح كبير دفعت لندن يتكلم عن
مجموعه من الطلاب من مختلف الجنسيات
الثمانينيات يدرسوا في لندن وكل واحد منهم
عنده افكاره مبادئه وحلمه وطموحه ومن
التناقضات اللي بينهم بتنطلق احداث
المسلسل اللي بيروي حكايات حب وغيره وشوق
للوطن والاهل وطبعا مثل الموسمان الماضيين
الجدل ما غاب عن ردات الفعل على المسلسل
ومن اول حلقاته
خذوا اللي علينا واللي مو علينا
[موسيقى]
ومن ضمن ابطال دفعه لندن الممثله السعوديه
ميله الزهراني اللي بتلعب دور عسل الطالبه
السعوديه المثقفه صاحبه الشخصيه القويه
والمتعصبه لافكارها واللي طموحها لدراسه
الطب في لندن خلاها تعمل اتفاق مع ابن
عمها وتتزوجوا عشان تقدر تسافر ميلا مو بس
من نجمات دفعت لندن لكن السنه هذه كمان
يبدو سانتها فهي كمان وجهه اساسي من وجوه
العمل الدرامي الضخم سفر برلك واللي بتلعب
فيه دور هند صفر بيجمع قصص حب وحرب وماساه
وبطوله وتضحيه واستقلال في قالب تاريخي
وبتدور احداثه قبل وخلال فتره الحرب
العالميه الاولى المسلسل هذا كان اخر
مشروع للمخرج الكبير الراحل حاتم عالي
واللي كان بيشتغل عليه حتى ايام قليله من
وفاته واستلم اخراجه من بعده الليث حجو
صناع العمل ومش اركيه اهدوا لروحه ميلا
كانت روجت للعمل عبر حساباتها وقالت انه
العمل الملحمي الاضخم وانه عمل بروح
الراحل حاتم علي
وتنضم الينا الفنانه ميلا الزهراني اهلا
فيكي معانا يا ميلا وكل عام وانت بالف خير
يا هلا وغلا يا ساره كل عام وانتم بخير
شهر مبارك على الجميع على الجميع ان شاء
الله يا رب علينا وعليك كمان
السنه ما شاء الله يعني عملين ضخمين فعلا
يعني دفعه لندن وسفر برلك كل احد بيتفرج
بيقول هدولي من اكبر انتاجات العام تعتقدي
انهم نزلوا مع بعض كويس لكي ولا لا شويه
يعني كنت تفضلي لو يكونوا متبعدين شوي
شوفي الموضوع يعني شوي قعدت اتكلم فيه
فعلا يعني كان مخوفني خاصه انه انعرض
مسلسل فقط ايضا قبل رمضان وانتهت الحلقه
الاخيره ليله رمضان فكان الموضوع شوي يخوف
بس لما فكرت فيها من ناحيه اخرى انا انا
من سنتين معرض لاي شيء تماما
فقلت لا فرصه يعني اتوقع انه جاء الوقت
المناسب انه الناس تشوفني الحلو في
الموضوع انه شخصيات الثلاثه تماما مختلفه
والمسلسلين فعلا قاعدين نعرضون ورا بعض
اوقاتهم بعد ورا بعض ولكن كان من ناحيه
ايجابيه لي انك قدرت ابين قديش شخصيتين
مختلفه وهذا الشيء يعني اعتقد ان شاء الله
يفيدني
يعني الاثنين في الماضي بس انه مع ذلك
ايوى مختلفين انت سفر برلك بس اصلا خلينا
كمان نوضح زياده للجمهور انت اصلا مصورته
من قبل منتهيه منه من اول
صح من سنتين انا مصورته واخذ وقت يعني في
يعني عمل ضخم بصراحه كان يحتاج الوقت هذا
وبصدق انه ينعرض يعني في نفس الوقت
تقولي مثلا ايش اللي لفتك فيه انك تشاركي
في عمل من هذا النوع هل كان عندك لقاء مع
حاتم علي قبل رحيله مثلا تقدري تحكي لنا
اي تفاصيل يعني
للاسف لا الله يرحمه ويغفر له مكان ما
التقيت في المخرج العظيم الراحل حاتم علي
ولكن التقيت
اللي يدعمني وشجعني كثير والعمل صراحه من
اول ما تكلموا عنه انا رحت تجيب الكتب
وقريت عنه وكان عندي سبق يعني كان عندي
لمحه عنها كثير فحبيت انه يتكلم عن حقبه
تاريخيه فعلا مفقوده فعلا موثقه تاريخيا
فعلا نحتاج انه نعرف عنها كجيل او الاجيال
القادمه يحتاجون يعرفون التفاصيل الحقيقيه
والصحيحه عن عن هالفتره وعن الاحداث اللي
صارت فكنت جدا متشجع ان انا اشارك فيه
والحمد لله كنت محظوظه مني اكون واحده من
الممثلات اللي موجودين في العمل اذا بدي
انقلك على دفعه لندن دفعه لندن على العامل
يعني ضجه يعني مختلفه تماما طبعا هو عمل
جماهيري يمكن اكثر من سفر برلك من ناحيه
انه الناس من جوز باله لانه ما شاء الله
كلكم مجموعه كبيره موجودين في وفي جدل ومش
ايش الكلام هذا كله كيف كنت وحده من دفعه
لندن كيف تم اختيارك
كانت الشخصيه كويتيه وبعدين تحولت لشخصيه
سعوديه الخط عجبني الخط مختلف الخط يعني
يتكلم عن عن بنت تستوي تحقق احلامها بس
بالحقبه هذيك صعب الموضوع انها تسافر لندن
لوحدها وعندنا زواج اني دائما يقولون
مربوطه الولد عمه وزوجته من الصغار ففعلا
كيف قدرت يعني تستغل
الفكره هذه وانها فعلا تتزوجها عشان تسافر
وتدرس برا بس الاحداث يعني معقده الاحداث
فيها فيها كثير من الواقعيه فيها كثير من
من بنات انا اعرفهم شخصيا انه فعلا تزوج
ولد اولاد عمهم عشان لمجرد انهم يسافرون
او كان في اتفاق بينهم هم يعتبرونهم
اخوانهم
فالصراحه عجبني الخط حسيته شوي مختلف
حسيته شوي
يتكلم عن عن اشياء حلوه يعني هبه مشاري
حماده طبعا الكاتبه المعروفه بنوجه لها
طبعا تحيه معروفه انه هي دائما عندها كثير
من الخط وط في اللي بتعملها يعني في
مسلسلاتها فعندنا مثلا هنا خط انتوا لما
مع بعض في الشقه سواء انه كويتيات سعوديات
مع بعض وكذا في خط القصه الايرانيه في
خاصه القصه العراقيه وما الى ذلك تعتقدي
هذا الشيء لانه الناس بينتقدوا كثره
الشخصيات في المسلسل في ناس عاجبهم بس في
ناس بينتقدوا انت ايش رايك في هذا الموضوع
اعتقد ان موهبه كاتب يعني الاستاذه هبه
مشاري يعني عندها القدره انها تكتب على
الخطوط هذه كلها في عمل واحد وما يفقد اي
خط حصه او اهميته هذا الشيء صراحه مو سهل
على اي كاتب بالعكس انا احييها انه انه
تقدر تسوي اعمال بالطريقه هذه مو دائما
الموضوع هذا يكون يعني سهل لانه لو
تلاحظين بعد ما يتابعون المسلسل كل الخط
له قصه المختلفه تماما كل خط له قضيه كل
خط وانها تنجمع في عمل واحد احنا في عصر
السرعه فنحتاج كذا نخلص
مسلسل
اكيد سمعت الكلام عن الجراه وما الجراه
يعني حتى انت شخصيتك بتذكر كلمات يعني
اعتبروها البعض جريئه كيف بتحسي شوفي احنا
هنسميها جريئه بس هما في ناس اعتبروها
خارجه قالوا لا تليق برمضان ولا النوتي
تنعرض على التلفزيون
بالنسبه لشخصيه عسل لا ابدا ما كان في اي
جراه في الحوارات وكنت انا يعني حريصه على
الموضوع هذا ما في مكان الكركتر يتحمل اي
جرعه يعني الموضوعها جدا خطا اوريدي معقد
فما تحتاج اي اي شيء بالنسبه لبعض الكلمات
انا انا ما اشوف انها انا اشوف انه بنات
يعني شويه في واقعيه انا اشوف انهم بنات
في شقه
طبيعي يعني انه يصير بينهم بس برضه اترك
الرد يعني لاصحاب الموضوع بس انا بالنسبه
لي يعني
ما اشوف انه
يعني انت طبعا لانك مشاركه اصلا في العمل
يعني بالتاكيد انه هذا يعني الشيء الاساس
فيه هبه مشاري حماده والمخرج طبعا ولكن
انتم الناس اللي بتكتب اساميكم على تويتر
جالسين ماسكين في اساميكم انتم انه
الحوارات هذه انتم كانكم بتقولوها
صحيح وخاصه انه هبه يعني الاشخاص اللي
يصرون دائما على انه ما يتغير الحوار وانه
يكون موجود مثل ما هو لانه تتعب في
الحوارات وتكتبها بعنايه تكتبها على
الشخصيه
ففعلا يعني احيانا يعني لازم يقولون نفس
الكلام بالضبط
ارجع اقول يعني انه ماني شايفه انه في اي
شيء بالعكس لو استمرون في المتابعه راح
يفهمون القصه راح يفهمون مبررات كثيره بس
المشاهد يعني ما يقدر يحكم من اول حلقات
يعني صح لا انا كمان يعني مثلا اذا الواحد
يطالع لمسيرتك يعني
ابتديتي باعمال وخلينا نقول كل مالك ما
شاء الله بترفع السقف على نفسك ترفعي
السقف يعني الان بتقدمي اعمال نوعيه معينه
عندك فيلم شاركتي فيه في مهرجان
من بطولتك يعني كانه ميلا عاده حساباتها
ولا ايش اللي صار ايش نقطه التحول
فعلا يعني الواحد يتعلم
مستحيل يعني الواحد تقريبا له خمس سنوات
مالي فتره كبيره بس اعتقد انها كانت كافيه
بالنسبه لي اعرف ايش اللي يناسبني اعرف
ايش
العمل اللي فعلا راح يكون راح ينتج بطريقه
صحيحه او راح يعني احيانا في ورق بس ينتج
بطريقه خاطئه الضحيه الممثل هنا بديت اعرف
هذه الاشياء وما زلت اتعلم يعني لسه توني
في اول عتبه بس رغم كده وقعت ضحيه لرامز
الصراحه نشوف حلقه حنسمع جعير وصريخ يعني
والله بهذلني صدق يعني
يعني حرفيا ما توقعت لدرجه انه في في وقت
ما شفت كاميرات وعرفت انه مقلب بس ما
توقعت انه رامز اوكي بس كان نفسي اضربه
بصراحه يعني
لا ما ضربتين خلاص
كذا بعدين يقولوا السعوديات ما يضربوا ما
ياخذوا حقهم يعني شوفي هو
اللي جاه بس يعني
بالضبط يعني لازم كده تكوني قويه في هذه
المواقف قولي لي يعني الان لو احد جلال
وبنت الملاكم ايه بالضبط اسمع يعني الان
الناس حتقول لك كنتي عارفه عن الموضوع
وماخذه فلوس انت اللي كنت عارفه ولا ماخذه
فلوس ولا امي ورش بنتي اني ما كنت ادري
ولا نص البرنامج انا ما كنت ادري لين عرفت
انه مقلب البرنامج لين لين عرفت انه رامز
اوكي بس انت ماخذه فلوسة الزهور يعني طبعا
ايه يعني كبرنامج عادي مع كارلا حداد
على السيره انت ذكرتي الان بنتك الله يخلي
لك اياها تالا كثير ناس ينصدموا انه انت
عندك بنت يا ميلا خلينا نشوف صورتها كمان
انت في مره نزلتي فيديو معاها يعني ما شاء
الله بنتك عمرها 12 سنه
13 سنه داخله 14 ما شاء الله طب بس يعني
تزوجتي صغيره ولا ايش صار ايه يعني تزوجت
على 19 اوكي خلاص الناس حسب عمرك انتهى
الموضوع دائما اقول اصلا ما عندي شيء خلاص
دائما اقول بس تقولي كمان انه موضوع
الزواج بالنسبه لك مو مناسب يعني خلاص انت
مكتفيه بحياه الفن الان وبنتك وكذا
احس انه بنتي وماما يعني
ملين علي حياتي وشغلي فما في وقت حتى ما
حد بيتحملني ما اتوقع في زوجي بيتحمل انه
انا
يتحملك يا ميلا ما شاء الله عليك يعني
رائعه انت شخصيه رائعه وما شاء الله عليك
وجهك زي القمر وكلك صراحه تجنني يعني
وموهوبه وكل شيء بمعنى اسمك او هذا مو
اسمك الحقيقي صح موميله لا لا لا اسمي
الحقيقي اسم فني يعني كنت اشجع فريق
وبعدين بتصل لحد ما لا
حلو حلو الموضوع
اسمك الحقيقي هبه صح اسمي الحقيقي هبه طيب
شكرا لك وكل التوفيق وان شاء الله كل
رمضان وطول السنه تكسري الدنيا بكل اعمالك
كانت معنا الفنانه ميلا الزهراني شكرا لك
الفنان ماجد المصري بيطلع على الجمهور في
هذا الموسم الرمضاني بدور ضرب نار في
مسلسل ضرب نار وعمل عامل اصداء من اولى
حلقاته ومن قبل حتى اولى الحلقات ماجد
كمان كان شوق الجمهور للدار
السنه دي وانت بتتفرجوا على مسلسل ضرب نار
خلي بالكم طلقه تطلع كده تطلع كده انا مش
مسؤول كل سنه وانتم طيبين ماجد المصري
ماجد المصري بيلعب في المسلسل دور زيدان
رجل الاعمال المتزوج وعنده بنت لكن بيوقع
في حب مهره اللي بتقوم بدوره ياسمين عبد
العزيز واللي قلبها معه احمد العوضي اللي
هو جابر في المسلسل ومن هنا بتبدا
الخلافات والصراعات المسلسل
اللي بياكل من تحت لتحت لازم يفهم الاصول
شغل الشمال لاسور احنا صعايده ولا انت
رجاله
مع زيدان ما ينفعش يخون ومعنى من القاهره
النجم ماجد المصري اهلا فيك معنا وكل عام
وانت بالف خير ماجد هلا بك يا ساره واهلا
بكل الساده المشاهدين كل سنه وحضراتكم
طيبين ورمضان كريم يا رب ان شاء الله
علينا وعليك يا رب
اتكلمت انت عن هذا المسلسل قبل ما ينزل
وقلت انه دور مختلف ليش مختلف بالنسبه لك
شخصيه زيدان شخصيه محيره شويه
يعني دايما مش هتبقي عارفه اذا كان هو طيب
ولا هو شرير يعني كيف الحلقه الثانيه
بيقتل
وقع في حب مهره
فاحنا مش عارفين زيدان ده ايه حكايته
بالظبط يعني هو شخصيه بالنسبه لي انا وده
يمكن كان سبب موافقتي على الدور انه انه
مش شخصيه ماشيه على تراك واحد يعني هي
شخصيه فيها ازدواجيه شويه عارفه ازاي انا
بالنسبه لي شخصيه جديده قابلتني على الورق
من
الكاتب الموهوب الكبير الاستاذ ناصر عبد
الرحمن
ما قدرتش طبعا ان انا اتراجع لحظه واحده
يعني
وحتى يعني نحن شفناك في المسلسل انت عامل
في البدايه انه بيبين انه رجل الاعمال
اللي غني مره وكده بعدين فجاه لقيناك فجاه
طلعت ابن بلد ابن بلد يعني يعني
تمام وفجاه العيون دمعت قدام ياسمين يعني
صراحه ايه لا لا عامل لنا شويه كده يعني
يعني خلينا نقول لخبطه كيف كان العمل بس
مع ياسمين واحمد خصوصا حيصير بينكم كثير
ضرب نار يبدو ضربه على الشاشه طبعا مش
يعني مش
حبايبي واخوات طبعا ياسمين طبعا
اختي وطبعا يعني بيننا علاقه طيبه طول
العمر الحمد لله وكان احمد كمال واحمد
كمان شخصيه محترمه جدا جدا واخ عزيز وغالي
يعني
واحنا على مستوى الفني طبعا عايزين نطلع
حاجه تسعد الناس والناس تشوفها وتتبسط
ويبقى كل واحد بيلعب في التراك بتاعه كل
واحد بيلعب شخصيه مختلفه
جابر ابو جديد بيلعب شخصيه مختلفه مهرب
والليل شخصيه مختلفه زيدان شخصيه كل واحد
له يعني بس هنا المؤلف يعني شاطر في ان هو
ازاي بيخلي الخطوط دي تتلاقى مع بعضها
ويحصل ما بينهم
الخلاف والحب والدموع والهدر ونشوف بقى
لسه مش عايز احلق طبعا
الناس بيقولوا انك دايما بتطلع في دور
الشرير ليش دايما
شايفاني الشرير لا انا مش شايفاكش غير
ابدا انت وكل اللي بيعرفوك بيقولوا انه
انت دمك زي العسل
انا
يعني لمهره وفي حته تانيه لا زي ما انت
قلت قتل واحد احترت صراحه مش عارفه يعني
بس يعني
هو طبعا هو اكيد يعرف مهره من زمان مش
ممكن يعني عشان شافها مره ولا اتنين فرح
لها البيت يعني ضربت العكره فخلاص لا اكيد
طبعا هو عينه على بكره من زمان وده لسه
هنعرفه يعني
طريقه الكتابه بتاعه الاستاذ ناصر عبد
الرحمن بيعمل ايه
بيعمل مثلا مشهد فممكن مشاهد يقول لك ايه
طب هو لحق يحبها امتى ولكن هو بيجاوب على
كل الاسئله دي بس لسه لما نكمل اوكي لما
نكمل العبره والنهايه يعني لازم نتفرج
الاول ما نحكمش عن عمل كده على طول بسرعه
من اول الحلقه 10 حلقات
لازم نتفرجها على المسلسل كله وبعد ما
نتناقش ونقول راينا طيب والستات على تويتر
وفيسبوك وكده زعلانين كيف رفضتك مهره في
حمله كبيره ههه في حمله كبيره لمساندتك
كيف رفضت تتزوج منك مهره امورك ماشيه مع
المعجبات يا ماجد الحمد لله
يعني بشكرهم طبعا
وعايزهم طبعا يعني يكتبوا كتير طبعا عشان
مهره توافق يعني
[ضحك]
واضح من عينيه لا هو في امل يتغير الموضوع
خالص
هو بيتقدم لها كرجل
وكان حتى اسلوبه معاها ما فيهوش تعالي او
الاداء نفسه
اه يعني راجل طبيعي جدا بجد بيتكلم بمنتهى
المشاعر بيحب واحده
بغض النظر بقى هي في نفس المستوى او اقل
او او لاخره مش ده الموضوع خالص الموضوع
قال الراجل ده صادق ولا رايح يشتري فقرها
عشان هو مليونير او عنده مصانع المصانع
بتاعته ودي مجرد واحده بتشتغل عنده لا هو
بيحبها فعلا فعلا بيحبها واحبها بجد ما هو
بيقول لها عشان كده انت مختلفه يعني قلت
لك انك مختلفه لما رفضته ايوه لا لا كان
مشهد مؤثر يا ماجد انا فاكرك بفصل
بس خليني كمان انجلد على رمضان هذا كان
الكل متوقع كمان حتكون موجود في مسلسل اخر
يمكن مع النجمه غاده عبد الرازق بعدين
قالوا انك انسحبت بعدين يعني هل كان في
هذا المشروع ولا بس كلام اعلامي لا كان
فعلا مشروع موجود
المنتج ممدوح شاهين ولكن لقله الوقت فعلا
انا اعتذرت فعلا لان فعلا مفيش وقت انا
احنا لحد دلوقتي احنا لسه بنصور بصراحه
لكن طبعا لو كان في فرصه وقت طبعا انا
يشرفني اشتغل مع غاده واشتغل عمل كبير زيت
التلاته انتم يعني عملته مع بعض نجاح كبير
قبل كده بس سبق الاصرار
والخانكه كمان
مبروك مقدما يا غاده ولما لقاء اخر ان شاء
الله طب خليني كمان على حياتك الشخصيه
خليني اتكلم معاك عن انت عندك ابن موهوب
وحابب
وحابب انه يدخل في هذا المجال والكلام هذا
كله بس الان الفتره الاخيره لو تلاحظ في
كثير انتقادات على موضوع دخول ابناء
الفنانين للعمل
ادم احمد
لا بتكلم على ادم
بس انا قررت ان انا انا مش هساعده في حاجه
لان هو وهو مش عايزني اساعده هو بيعتمد
على نفسه
وهيعرف يوصل ان شاء الله
ولو في فرصه انا هقدمه اتقبلت قبل ما
اتقبلش انا ما عنديش مشكله خالص لان
شغلنتنا ما فيهاش مجاملات بمعنى يعني لو
كان مثلا ابناء الراحل الاستاذ صالح سليم
مثلا بيعرفوا يلعبوا كوره كان وقتها رئيس
نادي الاهلي كان زمانهم بيلعبوا كوره لكن
الجمهور مش هيقبل فانا لو ابني بيعرف يمثل
الجمهور هيقبله ما بيعرفش يمثل
ولو لو لو اي فنان النهارده تواجد على
الساحه الفنيه وهو والده فنان مثلا او من
عائله فنيه صدقيني هو لو مش شاطر
مش هيعرف نفسه المنافسه قويه جدا عارفه
ازاي لكن لو عندنا لو عدينا كل اللي
موجودين دلوقتي مثلا محمد عادل امام نجم
وجماهير كبيره وناجح جدا جدا كريم محمود
عبد العزيز برضو نفس الموضوع احمد زكي
رحمه الله عليه المكان موجود الله يرحمه
طبعا احمد السعدني اه طبعا يعني
هنا بنقول لا عشان ولاد فنانين لا في
جينات موجوده يا جماعه وفي ناس من بره
الوسط واهاليها مش فنانين وعباقره في
التمثيل وفي الاخراج وفي السيناريو وكل
حاجه دي موهبه ربنا سبحانه وتعالى بيمني
بها على البني ادم ما نقدرش ان احنا نتكلم
او نقول لا ليه ومش ليه لا هو شاطر هيعرف
يثبت وجوده
في السوق
بالزبط
طب انا بتمنى لك طبعا التوفيق والمسلسل
حماسي جدا وبقول للناس يعني يتفرجوا عليه
لانه فعلا كل حلقه على الحلقه يعني اكثر
فانا متحمسه يعني
واحده واحده لان انا لو هتكلم على شخصيه
زيدان انا مش عايز احلق الشخصيه ولكن
بوعدهم ان هم الساده هيشوفوني انا شخصيا
طبعا المسلسل كله الحمد لله ناجح جدا جدا
جدا جدا جدا الحمد لله انا دلوقتي عشان
اللقاء انا بتكلم على شخصيه زيدان الشخصيه
مختلفه عليا جديده على المشاهد يعني انا
حاسس ان انا بقدم حاجه جديده وده شيء
بصراحه في متعه بالنسبه لي انا شخصيا يعني
يا رب
ان شاء الله وبقول لكل المعجبات يعني
يحاولوا
دماغ مهره شويه رجعت للمعجبات يعني نقطه
ضعف بصراحه
حلوه شفافيه والصراحه
اوكي انا ادري
طبعا شكرا لك يا ماجد نورتنا اليوم
بالتوفيق جدا شكرا شكرا
مع السلامه
من بعد ما كانت غايبه عن الموسم الرمضاني
2022 هذا الموسم بيطل علينا في مسلسل
واخيرا اللي بيشاركها في البطوله الفنان
قصي وحقيقه في كل عمل بيعملوه مع بعض
بيحققوا ثنائيه جميله وبيفاجئوا محبينهم
مره بعد مره مسلسل واخيرا عمل الدعوه وهو
هذا عمل درامي اجتماعي مليان تشويق واثاره
وبيتكلم عن قصه حب بين خيال اللي هي نادين
نجيم وياقوت اللي هو قصي وبيستعرض صعوبات
ومشاكل بتواجه الثنائي والمسلسل المحقق
نجاحات كبيره ترى من اول حلقه له فهو
الاكثر مشاهده على منصه شاهد في عدد من
الدول العربيه
[تصفيق]
قصتنا اليهود
[موسيقى]
لكن رغم النجاح الكبير يبدو انه نادين مو
راضيه كثير عن العمل وفاجات كل الناس على
تويتر باكثر من تغريدا انتقدت فيها بنفسها
مسلسلها والسبب بحسب كلامها انه في مشاهد
محذوفه كلوزات مثل ما قالت انرمت من دون
اي تبرير وقالت انه هذا الشيء بخليها تحس
بالقهر لانه بتشتغل من قلبها هي وبتلاقي
النتيجه شيء ثانيه وعلى فكره اللي بتقولوا
نادين كنا سمعنا اصوات بتقولوا على تويتر
فشفنا بعض التعليقات على التقطيع في
المسلسل واختيار زوايا التصوير
هند نزار من الاسماء الفنيه اللي صارت جزء
اساسي من دراما رمضان والسنه الثالثه على
التوالي بنشوفها ضمن السباق الرمضاني وهذا
الموسم بتشارك في بطوله مسلسل
المتمرد هند بتلعب دور هديل اللي وصفتها
انا معتياديه ولا طبيعيه وقالت انها من
اصعب الشخصيات اللي قدمتها او انها من
خلال هذه اللي بتكون لم الطلب جمهورنا
تعمل دور بعيد عن البيئه الريفيه
علاقتي بسيط مو علاقه محاميه الموكمات
ولا تخلط الامور
بسرعه
هند نزار اهلا فيك معنا يا هند كل عام
وانت بالف خير
اهلا وسهلا ساره رمضان كريم عليكم ان شاء
الله علينا وعليك يا رب هند خلاص صرتي من
اساسيات رمضان كل رمضان لازم نستنى عمل
وننبسط نحن نجيب لازم في تفاعلكم تطلعي
معانا
كل رمضان موجوده على الشاشه ان شاء الله
ان شاء الله يا رب من نجاح لنجاح بس هذه
السنه نقدر نقول هند بنشوفها بطريقه
مختلفه الصراحه عن المرات الماضيه
نعم لانه بصراحه يعني انا هم حبيت اشوف
نفسي بشكل جديد وشخصيه جديده يعني
دائما
الشخصيات اللي اخذها تكون الفقيره
والبنت الريفيه بس هالمره يعني انا هم
عجبني ابدل البس اشوف نفسي بغير ادوار
وبغير والصراحه يعني
نهائيا
كان اول ظهور للشخص العالم كانت منتظره
والحمد لله والشكر لاصدقاء تجنن لحد الان
عليها امس كان كذا في دخول درامي
لشخصيتك ايش نتوقع في الفترات الجايه لانه
يعني انا وانا بتفرج اوكي في طبعا بطل
الملاكمه وفي البنت اللي بيحبها وبعدين
فجاه بتدخل علينا هند ايش نتوقع الدراما
حب دخول ايش حيصير
يعني
اتوقع هو راح يصير يعني ناس البارحه الناس
بدات تتوقع الاحداث انه البنت تموت واني
اجي اخذ حبيبها
والناس قالوا لا يعني هن زوجه واحد ثاني
بالمسلسل فاني حابه هذا يعني هذا التفاعل
والناس قالت انه اني طالعه شريره يعني
حابه كل هذه الاشياء تقريبا فعلا كل شيء
هم متوقعين راح يشوفون داخل الشخصيه
بشخصيته اه والله حمستيني ايش اكمل
المتابعه لانه ايه لانه حسيت انه كده انه
ايش في هند ايش حيكون وضعها طب هو ورادي
عنده حبيبه واحنا متعودين في المسلسل لازم
تنحبي
طالعه يعني اكيد تطلع فهمت تطلع حبابه
واحد يعني ايه لا ما دائما انت طيبه
شويه طيب بس خليني كمان اقول لك انه يعني
انت فعليا فعليا نقيتي العمل عشان تطلعي
من موضوع خلاص هذا البيئه الريفيه ولا انه
صدف وجالك هذا العمل ولا عن قناعه انت
اخذتي مصاري مختلف حسيتي انه خلاص
بالكتابه وبادي والكواليس فقلنا انه اتمنى
انه اني واني هم اقترحت انه اتمنى انه
اكون بشخصيه محاميه او
لانه يعني كان ببالي هذا الدور انه هو راح
يتناول قضايا او ملفات نفتحها نسائيه من
هذا الباب اني كنت رايته رايده انه محاميه
وتدافع عن النساء او عن المراه برافو الله
لمن انكتب يعني اجا بهذا الشكل وهذا اللي
انا يعني
بس اكيد ما يخلى من الحب ومن
العذاب والاكشنات
يعني الحب بالقضيه لازم شويه شي زين انت
تقولي لي اها انت تحسي ان المراه مظلومه
فحابه انك انت يعني تاخذي او تعملي ادوار
فيها رساله عن المراه
ايه يعني هذا اللي دائما احاول اوصله من
خلال كل عمل اقدمه بكل دور اللي احاول انه
يكون به رساله تخص المراه والحمد لله
بالاعمال اللي فاتت يعني هذا الرساله كانت
موجوده
المراه مثلا خصوصا المراه العراقيه
يعني
دائما تنظلم من البيئه ومن العائله مرات
يعني اني انقهر لما يكون هو الظلم متزوجها
او يكون من اخوها او يكون من ابوها هذا
هذا يعني انه اذا هم هذول اللي المفروض
يكونون سندها هذولا يكونون عليهم فهي شلون
راح تواجه مجتمع كامل فهذا اللي اللي اني
دائما اشوفه بمجتمعنا للاسف وهذا هم وحده
من الملفات او يمكن ملفين بقضيه هديل راح
تدافع عن عن وحده عن هيجي قضيه يعني نسيت
تريدي تحشي
بدات ايه
يعني من ملف احنا نفتحها عن
اغلبهم للاسف حتى بالنص مكتوب انه فعلا هم
يعانون من اللي داير مدايرهم ومن المجتمع
الفتره الاخيره بس على الاقل يعني شفنا
انتعاشه
للاعمال العراقيه يعني قبل كم سنه كانت
الاعمال العراقيه خلينا نقول قليله محليه
جدا الان ويمكن كمان ام بي سي العراق لها
دور في هذا الموضوع يعني صار في انتعاشة
بتحسي بهذا الموضوع
شوفي الحمد لله والشكر اني يمكن اول بارحه
بيني وبين نفسي اقول الف الحمد لله والشكر
انه
الدراما العراقيه من تعشه ومنطلقه بشكل
كبير ومني يعني حتى مو محلي الموضوع يعني
الموضوع عربي يعني
المسلسلات تشاهد عربيه الحمد لله والشكر
فهذا الشيء فرحني وام بي سي عراق هي
يعني اقدر اقول وبكل ثقه انه هي وضعت هذا
الحجر الاساس للمنافسه ولدخول او رجوع
الدراما العراقيه فهذا مو غلط وهذا بالعكس
التنافس انا احبه والغيره الشريفه بالشغل
هي موجوده ولازم تكون موجوده وحلوه لما
تكون موجوده يعني اني افرح اليوم لمن اكو
بنات وياي موجودات بغير ام بي سي عراق
وداخل ام بي سي عراق وغير قنوات هم
يشتغلون حتى تكون اكو منافسه لما تكون اكو
روح منافسه كلنا راح نحاول نبدا وكلنا راح
نحاول نطلع اجمل ما عدنا فبالعكس هذا
الشيء فرحني وابارك للجمهور العراقي
وللعائله العراقيه واقول لهم انه خلي شويه
نبتعد عن الانتقادات
لانه الجمهور العراقي يهجم فشويه شويه
خليه يشوف هوايه اعمال بعدها ما طالعه
وهوايه اعمال بعدها ثالث حلقه او رابع
حلقه احنا اليوم برمضان فخلينا نشوف وخلي
ندعم لان هو ما يعرفون ايش قد الكواليس
الاعمال هي شقد متعبه وشقد ممكن واحد
نظرهم بيقولوا هذه الاعمال يمكن سيئه او
تسيء للمجتمع او مش عاجب او التمثيل
أنا بقول لك الكلام اللي بينقال
صوره عامه سرعه يعني اتمنى من الجمهور انه
بس انت كمان يا هند على طول هجموك
والله ما عندي مشكله بالموضوع الحمد لله
وال يعني مستمره واذا اقدم بنفس الوقت اذا
هاجموني عشره بالميه فانا عندي 90% ناس
تحبني اذا هاجموني 20% فاكو ناس تحبني
ثمانين بالمئه فاني دائما
وتسعين في المئه
الحمد لله والشكر يا ربي الحمد لله يعني
انا هذا الشيء ما انسى هذا هذا العراقي
اللي قدم لي اياه وهذا جمهوري العراقي
اللي انا ما اقدر انكر حبه وفضله علي بانه
انا وين اكون وهند وين هي اليوم هذا ولكن
لا زالوا الى الان يمكن هذه النقطه انا
تناقشت فيها مع اكثر من وجه عراقي من اللي
اصبحوا الان بارزين وبياخذوا بطولات اعمال
يعني في انت طبعا في مثلا الكسندر علوم في
كذا احد انه كثير ناس بيقولوا انه طب هم
ايش خبرتهم ياخذوا بطولات الاعمال
ويتصدروا الساحه الان لازال هذا الكلام
بيتكرر رغم انك صار لك الان يعني ايش ثالث
سنه في رمضان واعمالك الاثنين الباقيين
نجحوا وتصدروا المشاهده بيزعجك هذا الشيء
نعم
يعني زي شويه يرجعون عن البدايات او
التاريخ فانا يعني خلاص هاي فرصتي واستحق
اليوم اخذها اني صار لي عشر سنوات بالوسط
من 2013 او 2012 فهذه فرصتي اللي انا
استحقها واني عندي دراسه يعني جايتها وحتى
اللي يجيها يعني حب تكون عنده موهبه لكن
انا هذي فرصتي واتحقها واستحق اليوم اني
اكون موجوده واستحق اني اللي اخذ البطوله
هذا يعني هذا مكاني الحمد لله والشكر
فماما خذته من احد ثاني بنفس الوقت
الفرصه للشباب ولوجوه الجديده ما بيها اي
مشكله او خلل انه يطلع لنا وجه جديد اللي
بيه اللي عنده هذه الموهبه ويحملها وحريص
على الفن ويقدم برساله فاهلا وسهلا بيه
يعني احنا ما عندنا مشكله ويا اي احد يدخل
جديد او وجه جديد او لاول مره يمثل هند
انا جائع
ويحترمها انا بدي اقول لك حاجه انا معجبه
جدا بردك على هذا السؤال انا اعرفك من
سنين واحبك على مستوى
شخصي جدا لانه اعرف انت قد ايش الشخصيه
يعني طيبه وحبابه وكل هذا الكلام يعني
وخلال السنين تطورتي انا جدا حبيت الان
انك انت قلتي انه انا استحق وانه انا
استاهل وانه هذا مكاني يعني يمكن هذه
واحده من اكثر الاشياء النساء عندهم مشكله
فيها انه دائما يشكوا في نفسهم يسمعوا
للانتقادات وكذا كثير حبيت انك انت لا
عارفه قيمتك
الحمد لله والشكر يعني لازم كل واحد يكون
عارف قيمته حتى لان هذا استحقاقنا يعني
ساره منو يجي ياخذ يعني المهنه من عندنا
واحنا اللي دارسيها واحنا اللي يعني
مقاتلين حتى ناخذ هذا الفرصه اليوم ونكون
موجودين
فاني جمهوري احب كلامه اذا بالسلبي واذا
بالايجابي فاني اسمع من عنده واحبه
واتفهمة واتفهم انه هو يعني قاعد يريد
يستمتع ويريد يشوف عمل درامي يستحق وخلي
يكونون على ثقه كل الفنانين مو بس انا كنت
انا اليوم بكل فنان عراقي الفنان عراقي
حريص على انه يقدم
شيء نظيف مهم
محترف يا هند منحازه لك دائما لنجاحاتك
بالتوفيق دائما كانت معنا النجمه هند نزار
شكرا لك يا هند مشاهدينا نحن كمان وصلنا
لنهايه حلقتنا اليوم انا عدوه غدا ان شاء
الله في امان الله
[موسيقى]